hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription with
this guy i'm back after another respawn
and i checked around to see if there was
anything really quickly and i don't
think that there's anything else just
yet and also i think i realized that
those bears had like flying protection
so i don't think the flying ooh you
really would have been able to do
anything about that so i think it was
screwed anyway because the game wanted
me to loop back again but here i am
because it's fun
instead you must now decide on a tribe
that you prefer
what what
oh
right
i don't remember which one was which
besides the wolf being in that one i
know that one was like snakes and stuff
not really my jam with all the poisons
maybe the elks that had like the the
bears no it was a bit nah
well you're not the black goat that i
was hoping you were or i'm glad you're
not who whatever randomly chosen hooved
card do you wish for something else
no
i'm good i'm good with that i'll take
that
that's fine with me
or right off the bat with a totem
an ancient woman emerged from behind an
oak tree who totems for me she carefully
lay down intricate wood carvings then
gestured at them bruskly
the undying i like that undying thing
that was fun last time whoa
the squirrel of the undying
the old woman bared her teeth in
satisfaction your first totem was
complete
the unkillable sigil will now be marked
upon all your squirrel creatures
oh
that's really good
that's real real big good also what does
that do i don't know whatever i probably
won't be able to get to use the totem
all the
time nice
so you got the flying defensible good
thing i never do the flying defense
thing me again
all right cool it's you again hey that's
great what do you got over there
oblonghorn
longhorn i think that said longhorn
whatever
let's put you there no
damn it i just realized i forgot he was
unkillable because i know that guy does
dab legend tudor oh
shoot well i might be able to do
something about that actually no this
will work out
unkillable oh come back to my handable
though
that's even better that solved all my
problems because i can put you there
then you're unkillable or you come back
that which is amazing and then i put the
stoat out the stoke can take that hit
the squirrel it doesn't matter you'll
come back to my hand anyway i forgot
it's not just unkillable he comes back
to my hand every time which is dope as
hell this game is going to be easy
[Music]
put you right
there
back on the board and then put you down
kill you and
you i guess and wolf goes right back
there because it's going to kill that
that's pretty good
cool all right let's keep going
i've almost won this already in one fell
swoop
try me
enough uh whatever
oh
handy that
ah well that's not very helpful uh let's
go ahead and win this
boing boink
easy victory
and tooth in the pot
thank you for being such a
[ __ ]
more cards please
now that i don't have my hand oh
interesting bugs okay bugs is a bit more
complicated i do like the i think i want
the more expensive things oh well that's
helpful well that was short-lived
yeah i do want the more expensive things
though because i think it's going to
help the bones of the ancient woman
creaked and groaned as she approached
with gently shaking hands she placed her
offerings before you
oh
what does that mean what does a raven
mean is this so i can make a completely
different totem i think that might be
just so i can make another totem
entirely because if i have another base
but only one head then i don't think i
could make anything
what am i doing
[Music]
what
ah
right okay so the squirrels are affected
by that by having that as the squirrel
one the bird one i don't even know if i
get to pick that one i didn't want any
different one than that one i think i
was fine
i think that's fine
i think anyway
thank you bud
that happens every time nice top deck oh
this is a nice top deck oh
a wolf cub you are wolf cubbed
keep me alive and we'll see what happens
like uh how about maybe not
how about maybe uh no
all right cool
dope as hell
get ready for splash damage [ __ ]
hell yeah
hell yeah i love these squirrels i love
these squirrels
i love these squirrels
i love the squirrels
excellent excellent
excellent now what is that i'm always
down to try something new as opposed to
that which is the trapper and i don't
like him anymore because he's kind of a
dick so let's try the mine
you came across a hobbled man standing
beside some boulders
you caught me off guard
not supposed to see me till further down
the road see
i like me a gamble
if you can pick a boulder that has gold
in it you can keep it
all right uh middle
well oh
i can barely abide giving it to you but
a promise is a promise where i'm from
well thank you appreci i preach
all right i don't really have that many
to sacrifice other than the goat i think
oh i forgot you were there am i your
choice oh you might be
uh you might be give me your stink
yeah let's put the let's combine our two
talking cards let's combine them yeah
why not take that
fine choice
wow
[Music]
now i got a stinky weasel
hell yeah
thank you
yep uh-huh yep indeed all right what do
we got wolf cup there that's all right
let's put this
goat there
total miss play you're a total misplaced
screw you what are you talking about
[ __ ] you're a misplay
[Music]
as in you misplaced your
brain idiot
i miss play i'll miss you
[Music]
that's an easy game you can't do nothing
cub you forgot that you were stinky
stoked
oh yeah oh yeah now this is what i am
talking about are you guys ready for
some overkill let's see if i i don't
know if this is going to cause more
splash damage
like if i put this here is it going to
go past to him i have no idea let's see
nah
easy commies go
more cards please give me some big price
oh it's my other card i know the skink i
know what the skink do uh let's get the
marquee move this time the one i
i forgot yeah that was me that was me
all right um
i don't need another totem i got the
best totem there is i'm never gonna
change this totem
hi
like something else ah
i can make monkey move more powerful
why not right
warm that marky moo up
nice i made a hasty retreat with my
marquee moo you bet i did all right i'm
gonna steamroll this [ __ ]
give me the smoke
stand in the way of me goldie be darned
[Music]
oh hell yeah markimoo is on the board
baby markimoo is on the board and you
all are donezo you all are done so oh
this is so good for me oh this is so
good for me
okay this is what we're gonna do we got
our squirrel
we're gonna play our marquee moo
play the marquee move we're gonna put
our squirrel
and the smoke down
because i think you can still sacrifice
that yes you can chump
and i'll put this
uh actually this is pretty good both of
these are gonna go because they're gonna
you know he's gonna take him afterwards
but whatever but uh yeah that's a seven
damage on the first turn i think i'm
gonna win this
man you're bad at this
you're kind of bad man dude
there's gold nippy carrots
yeah i know i know i know
yeah i know i know gold is strict gold i
know i know all right now i'm kind of in
a pickle because i don't know what oh
man this is not the best
whatever
all right well at least i got defense
you know it's kind of nice all right uh
yeah that's all i can do for now
i'll chip away at you
i'll cheat
just pop that mule uh the mule's gone
bro mule's gone i forgot i forgot that
that was kind of like the idea of it but
uh the the mule's kind of gone
so uh about that is uh
not ideal
yeah okay you got stink don't worry
about it you're fine
well that doesn't help me
keep at it boys
you're doing great
you're doing wonderfully
oh hell yeah now we got it now we're in
it okay so i'm gonna do this to play
this so that i can place this so i can
place this
bam
bum buttom
and now it's death oh my deck is gone if
i'm out of cards do i just never have
cards oh that's a that's a bad or
whatever it do i don't need it
that's a lot of overkill my dude that's
a lot of overkill you're a lot of stupid
my dude
you're a lot of bad at this need a light
thanks
oh
yes please can i get a new you ruley i
would love a new year
i love it i love the who you ruling the
buzzing and chirping of insects drowned
out the sound of your footballs the
wetlands i gotcha let me take a look
around
there's got to be something else going
on here that's changed since the last
one cause there is this
oh
if i play that in this game i need to
play this i think i just got it this is
the game board these are the cards that
i need to play
ah interesting okay well that's not
gonna happen any time soonish so uh
yeah about that uh
oh thanks for the oh oh
that's many typhuses still don't know
the oh the fish hook grabs one of their
cards
okay
i don't know what that is that's funky
looking i don't need the totem but i
don't need the items either and that
thing that's a totem fight i don't know
what that is i kind of want to know
i might as well go this way this seems
better
oh kingfisher
slippery hunter uh let's go rattler
because i just so happen to be getting a
lot of bones from these squirrels
constantly dying so you know it's not
too bad
oh i do keep the beard she moved with a
certain vigor but in spite of her
considerable age
uh all flying bugs snakes bugs might be
cool if i ever get bugs but i don't
really have bugs
i'll go for the insect head
it's like i can build my totem i get it
but it's going to be the squirrels every
time i love that
totem all right my dude get ready to get
trounced
oh hell yeah
all right skook
get ready to
die you sure yes i'm sure stop
second-guessing my things you a-hole
i mean this is totally unnecessary but
whatever
let's go for the overkill
yep goodbye buddy
man when i can do seven damage in the
first turn
it's kind of easy i don't know what this
is but i'm curious
you arrived at the inky black mouth of a
cave oh
a strange beast looked within
it spoke past one of my trials and i
will be yours in a raspy voice
okay what does that mean three creatures
will be drawn from your deck they will
decide your success or failure but first
you will choose a trial
okay
trial of health three drawn cards must
have at least six health combined to
pass
trial of bones three drunk hearts must
cost at least five combined bones to
pass trial of blood three drunk cards
must cost at least four blood to pass
um i gotta you you ruley that's probably
the most likely i don't know well i
guess it would just be as likely with
the help but i don't have a lot of high
health things i'm going to go with the
the cost
let the trial of blood begin
i'll be my ass
eat my ass
i've passed the trial
the beast revealed itself it was
oh what
i'm sorry
but
i'm sorry what is the what is this what
is this
many lives okay apparently he's got many
lives uh i'll take this one
the inhabited joined your menagerie
i don't know what that means i don't
know what that means i don't need more
totems
that's really wonderful uh gonna go with
the
wolf
because i have wolf i do have wolf but
that's like squirrel ah
mushroom
i don't know what that is but i wanna
know
all right thank you
uh well i don't have my big damage
straight off the bat okay those are
gonna be i can never hit them so i'm not
too worried about that
um
uh at least i got markimoo here that's
good
oh but he can defend from those things
that might be so that might save me at
least one damage ah let's just keep it
clean i'll do four damage they do four
damage it'll be a wash but at least my
marking will stay alive
let's just keep them safe
keep me safe i guess
ok
take that
you
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna mess you
up man
i'm gonna mess you up my dude
i am about to mess you up my dude i
guess i could just win it yeah i'll just
win it why would i why would i wait
let's just win it let's just go for it
man my my wolf and me
wolfy moo combo is unstoppable all hail
the wolfimu
i don't want that the unappreciated
ringworm its value is not readily
apparent no it's not but maybe maybe
that's because it like infects whatever
attacks it or whatever it attacks or
probably whatever it attacks it
elusive otter submerges itself during my
turn well that doesn't look nice i'm
gonna go for the ring worm because i
like what you're saying with the whole
its value is not readily apparent i like
that idea about it and i kinda am always
curious to try new things
mushroom
ew
you find yourself among a grove of thick
and pungent mushrooms
you squinted to see a figure through the
thick cloud of spores
we are the mice
[Music]
yes
and we are performing our experiments
far from from
we are not welcome elsewhere
we will experiment on your flock yes
we will need two of the same creatures
one for each of us
well oh wow
well i got this wolf
so uh let's try that i
i think this could get messy
look away i'm gonna look right at it oh
the
wolf
it is now one
yeah it is buddy thank you for that
that's actually kind of helpful that's
actually dope as hell i like that a lot
oh ooh you really i can't play you god
damn it all right what are we looking at
what are we looking at what are we
looking at what are we looking at we're
looking at how to get the hell to get
this ruling off on the board if we can
get this who you're really on the board
this game over my booze this game over
my booze all i need to do is get a goat
or a markimoo and this who you really is
on the board baby that's who you really
is on the board i'll take that
you stink
idi
oh i gotta draw a goat damn it rattler
can i get the rattler if i oh no i can't
cause i can't just keep sacrificing it
well that stinks damn it
hey what happened to the stink hey the
stink hey what about my stink give me a
go god damn it okay you attack oh right
yeah you attack this ringworm and let's
see what happens oh it gets booned from
the alpha that's right i forgot about
that
ow
okay goat god damn it god damn it what
happened with the ringworm did the
ringworm do anything is the ringworm not
readily apparent is the value of the
ringworm not readily apparent because
there's no value at all
all right i know how to do this
watch this
i've got the perfect defense because
this squirrel there you go
man that's a lot of cards thank you
thank you can i get a freaking
goat
yeah that'll do that'll do that'll do
that markimoo will do because now i'm
going to kick all of your collective
asses
and i'm gonna okay this rattler can kill
but both of these any of these
let's put this down first let's put this
down okay you're gonna take care of
those guys
the uyu really is gonna come in
yep
i've been dying to do the uya ruli
kick their asses who you really and then
i'll defend with a squirrel
it's a perfect plan
[Laughter]
[Music]
there you are you son of a [ __ ] but it
don't matter because it's one
[Laughter]
baby oh you're really no joke my dude
that really is no joke you won't find
better pelts within a hundred miles
won't i
good god but i don't want these clogging
up my i don't really want it can i have
this one instead
can i have that one as well
thank you i'll take those
when do i turn these in i'd really like
to turn in the pelts please do i want
more power do i want to i want more
power on one of my cards
stop this oh you'll stop this oh i
forgot that my wolf was there what if i
enhance the ring worm then it can attack
is that kind of like what it needs to
happen
all right i have a ring worm now it can
attack now i don't know what good that
is
you told me that it wasn't readily
apparent maybe that's because it's not
existent
is that why it's not readily apparent
the mud tucked hard to your feet forcing
you to slow your pace wrangler cause
your eyes water yeah yeah yeah yeah
what if i take your card
goldfish everyone has the same ax in
here shut up all right cool i like this
all right i like this
okay all right okay
i like this
yeah i like this i don't mind this i
don't mind this yeah i don't mind
i don't mind this
i don't mind
what happened to that card that was like
a staticky too i don't remember i don't
i don't know where that went all right
i'll just keep these let's try this
damn look at that five damage off the
bat
just wait till i get my oo you really
[ __ ] go fish
all right so yeah you're gonna do the
chum buckets but uh joke's on you
damn it all right well so what there's
gonna be sharks it don't matter if
there's gonna be sharks because i'm
gonna steal your shark i will literally
steal your shark i'm gonna steal your
shark and there's not a goddamn thing
you can do about it i'm gonna steal your
shark
i'm gonna steal your shark
i'm gonna steal your shark come on give
me a good one god damn it
at least i know it's gonna be defending
can i steal a shark
can i steal your shark i stole your
shark
anyway let's put a let's put a squirrel
in the way of you
uh kill the squirrel i dare you
oh no my squirrel oh no oh
no oh
no
[Laughter]
i'm afraid you are a dead dead dead man
i got this freak wolf that is gonna
absolutely annihilate you good god get
ready to die
wow look at that
that's about as much overkill as i could
have possibly done i love that
wow you're bad at this
your lives are restored
thanks your lives are extinguished i
will choose so carefully give me a good
holy mantis god the perfect incarnation
of terror can attack in three directions
that's pretty cool
the pack rat never doubt the utility of
a well-stocked pack
you have a little tree for randomized as
long as you have less than three items
oh
i don't really care
the filthy feral hog it becomes incensed
when its chimes are struck
what when a curtis bearing this amount
of time is created on each md adjacent
times defined as
i'll take the pack rat because items
sound pretty cool that means i guess so
just get more items and whatever
all right whatever let's go with to the
winter zone hopefully there's no bear
stupidity that's going to happen
glow the snow line yeah
whatever this is i forget
ah you have you're the pelt guy i have
belts
i have a lot of pelts okay
bell ring refresh this ah every time i
ring the bell this does more damage
interesting that's fascinating i kind of
like that
i kind of like that a lot i don't have a
lot of bone playing things but so maybe
i should do a possum but honestly i kind
of like that that's a pretty good idea i
like the long-term potential of this one
could choose to be my downfall but
whatever
is that a golden help magnificent what
is that the card bearing is still this
is uh oh
weird i'll just take another uyuruli
because holy [ __ ] yeah i guess i can
pick three of these right i like the
amoeba the amoeba's fun he's pretty cool
i don't have any bones um i like the
amalgam and why not another ooh you know
what if i get the merger for the ou
rules what if i can merge them what if i
get to merge
ooh that's fun
there was something different you
intuited that the fate of the creature
selected for this would not be pleasant
oh
[Music]
yeah what's with this thing can i put
the ring worm on there because i i don't
really know what the ringworm does let's
just see what happens to the ringworm
you callously slaughtered the ringworm
however the bone lord was pleased by
your sacrifice
oh
a minor boon of the bone lord you will
start each battle with one bone thanks
you shook off the visor of the poor
ringworm and carried on i didn't know
what the ringworm did it was kind of
like a bunk so i whatever
whatever main
whatever mean
thanks
oh
you are very dead you are
unbelievably dead
god you're dead
oh my god you're dead
i love this i love this i love this a
lot
my man my guy i'm sorry
good night
i'll see you later
well that was easy
all right i don't need no pelts
elk alpha moosebook i got a lot of
things that cost
a high i'd rather keep that to the ue
roolies so i might as well do the elk
that's that's pretty stable
oh god what is that what is that what is
that oh oh no you can't use that
what is that failure to the user nothing
will happen this bottle of goo has no
use
well sounds like i'm taking this bottle
of goo sure do love a bottle of goo
you're dead
uh you're uh dear dad elk fawn uh sorry
about that but you're dead just so
happens uh you're dead
i hate to say it but uh you're dead
and that'll be
that
fun hey good game man good game good
game man good game i want another
power-up i do i do i do
all right what do we got magpie uh if
that's any car
i love that
i love that fetch and ah it's like uh
yu-gi-oh and the power of the
talisman of infinity whatever it was i
don't remember whatever it was it was
dope hello again the crackling fire lit
the starving faces of the group of
survivors we have no food
but perhaps one of your creatures will
join us enhance its health oh all right
nope nope nope uh how about you oh my
god my wolf don't look so good my wolf
ain't looking too hot all right um i
should probably increase the health of
this thing that way it could last longer
be more useful on its place or marky moo
i could buff him up now let's do this
thing
yeah
nice
all right time for another wash
uh yeah i'm sorry buddy uh
yeah you're dead again i don't feel bad
about it at all
i don't feel any kind of bad about it uh
goodnight what does this do i'll use it
on the next boss
maybe i'll use it when i get to the next
like hey you're too fast kind of thing
and maybe that'll give me a chance to
not
be too fast kind of thing you know what
i mean
yeah you know what i mean
great
what do we get here oh turkey
i need that
but magpie
but i needed to complete the puzzle i
this is a chance to complete the puzzle
if i could play it i could do this with
the back pie i don't i haven't even used
my magpie and this is just a good card
in general so why not
[Music]
all right get ready to die again and
this time it'll be fair
i'm afraid i must be skinning you today
it's not me that only has one accent
it's this guy that has only one accent
oh yeah i forgot all the traps i gotta
be careful about this well i could just
do you really it and actually no i can't
oh you really it but i can stode it at
least and that's something
i'll block it up with this and this and
that'll prevent me from getting any
damage all right
we're good
[Music]
i need
i'll i have to wait yep that's what i
was waiting for all right but then
there's a problem right
so if i play the uerule it's not really
going to be what i need
because then these are going to turn
into traps and the things are going to
die no matter what so i need to wait
until next turn because
markimoo is going to get sacrificed
anyway so we might as well be here and
that way i can keep him there for now
i'll put the squirrel back oh i can put
the i actually know the vulture is a
flying thing but that's actually not bad
i can play that now
here
it will get hit by that but it won't
kill it because it's not trapped yet
maybe when it turns into a trap it'll
kill at least this is something i think
i don't know that might have been a
mistake but whatever
yeah it did did turn into a trap okay so
this is just a wall of death anyway
so me playing the roolie isn't really
helpful
this is where i kind of need smaller
cards or else it's just gonna end badly
for me so all these guys are gonna die
and that's kind of a problem not ideal
not ideal
well that's a lot of wolf pelts
ow
hey [ __ ]
what do i need what do i need
please don't be oh interesting
oh bones okay okay okay so you can only
do one you can do three so i'm gonna
need to do is i need to defend that spot
first but what i could do is i could use
this to sacrifice both of those nah it's
probably best just to do this
and then put
this amoeba out
right put a wolf pelt down here wolf
belt's gonna be hit by a wolf okay we're
good
pack rat damn it god damn it not what i
need i guess i could do the emergency
squirrel
but would that even give me enough uh
yeah actually it would because they'd
both be unkillable
so then i killed both of those to get
say the pack rat out because i just used
an item
and i'll put the pack rat
it'll kill either of these so might as
well make the one that's more dangerous
killed i get pliers that's nice i can
put the elk out as well it could
definitely kill that thing
okay we're in business we're in business
we're still in business i've only i
haven't killed one life yet but we're
still in business
i got my squirrels
i should have just gotten a second
squirrel anyway because it's like that's
how i get the economy flowing i'm so
used to beating it in one go that i kind
of forgot that i didn't have to
okay
amalgam ooh
you're a squirrel you're everything oh
okay we got a bit of a problem because i
can't exactly kill you but i can get
bones back
oh this is delightful okay and then
because this is now officially
unkillable so i'm going to use it to go
here and get that trap out of the way so
that i don't have to worry about that
that's going to come and kill that elk
but that's fine because my u really will
come back and kick its ass we are good
to go
done
that's okay that's okay i needed to get
it out of the way
squirrel wrangler i don't even know what
that means what do you mean what are you
talking about
swiss belts but the cycle must continue
let's trade
okay trade what what are you gonna trade
whoa
powerful cards that will accept only the
finest belts for them afraid what you
can but know this the rest will stay and
fight for me
okay
well i did not pick one
i did not pick one ah right well okay
yeah i'm gonna go for that one that one
and that one because i just don't want
that big damage there i would have
chosen differently yeah well you're an
idiot so what do i value your opinion
about
[Music]
ah you're dead
hey you're dead packrat can't kill that
but i don't need the pack rat to kill
that because i just need to get one hit
literally i just need one hit from this
wolf
and it's game over
i love that for me
oh what are you doing there buddy
well fine you want to play it that way
you will die sorry pal you're going to
extremely die i guess i'm not going to
win this time but it don't matter it's
fine just going to put that there and
then you're going to hit this and that's
fine
because it don't make any difference
play it
hmm seems like i'm gonna win
seems like i'm gonna win super handily
okay so i'm not even gonna bother uh
blocking this because you're dead anyway
hmm
wow look at that you're dead wow look at
that you're dead
wow look at that you're oh
no you're dead
you will not perish quite yet
no i won't
perhaps one of these will entice you
the eternal serpent death strengthens it
forever i love that i love
i love that i love that i love that i
love that i want that and i love that
i love that and i want that when the
enigmatic trapper and traitor now
bleeding into the snow
you persisted
you could see a light in the distance
the end is near
the end is near huh but i i haven't even
i haven't even finished any of the
puzzles whoa
what is that about
i need to power up some cards
okay what do we got what do we got
there's two on the magpie i could put
two on something else yeah let's go
ahead and kill the magpie put it on the
markimoo
i like that i like that
gimme them
[Music]
marquee move is pretty tough
your eyes fix themselves on a small
cabin
it's warm light a beacon in the opposite
oppressive darkness of the night
surely
surely this cabin marked the end of your
travails
surely oh oh
i'm in the cabin right now i'm in a
cabin i am in the cabin oh god
oh god
oh
no
[Music]
hi
how are you doing
oh steps away from the strange cabin you
were presented with an opportunity
i don't offer my boons to just any
traveler
if you are able to pass my trials you
will be rewarded mightily
what is your trial trial of the winged
the three dawn sigils must include a
card with an airborne sigil
trial of the swift
sprinter
trial of rarity
oh well i have tons of rare cards i'm
gonna go with that one
come on rare
yes
i want it
ah amalgam is a rare card
success
i will grant you one of my most precious
boons cars that dramatically alter the
game and you don't even need to draw
them
boon of mag prize eye when you draw from
your deck you may choose any card in
your deck to draw
but with the forest you will start a
battle with grand furs on all of your
spaces i don't want that
boon of the bonelord
magpie it up give me the bag
we will repeat that once more oh
try out the skins okay i don't have many
pelts
ring i don't have any rings
ah there's gonna be a wash i don't have
any of these i don't do i i don't have
any pelts in my inventory right now do i
have any aquatic ones maybe like one i
don't know
i don't think i do but i definitely
don't have a ring that's for damn sure
yeah
all right
i know i i definitely don't have offend
failure i know i know i know but it's
okay that magpies eye i would love two
boons but you know i don't even need
you managed to get a boon
this may be a fair competition
what oh hi okay hey what's up hey what's
up
all right i'm going in
i went into the cabin i'm sure that's
symbologically impressible
oh hi oh hey
you took your time out there
and i'm itching for another game
are you ready to play uh yeah i guess i
okay here we go
i hope you are adequately prepared i i
don't know if i am i'm gonna put the
goop on you i'm gonna put the goop on
you man you're gonna get the goop
perhaps one more to be safe well that
hardly seems fair
well that hardly
that hardly seems fair
okay
well this is
just gorgeous ain't it
[Music]
oh you get all rare cards is that what
you get
oh is that what you get well that's
[ __ ] that's all right i ain't gonna
worry about it
i ain't gonna worry about it too much
this guy's just gonna defend anyway so i
might as well put her there
hello and
how y'all
i'll save the oh next time oh
i could play the squirrel in the vulture
i could play the scroll in the vulture i
could do that thing i might be able to
unlock it
oh okay well i was i wasn't prepared for
that i forgot to put down a thing i i
that was my bad
okay
your choice yeah it is my choice okay
what do i need what do i need didn't my
amalgam have infinite ability wasn't my
amalgam like an unkillable what happened
by amalgam's unkillability all right i'm
definitely going to get the marquee moo
and markimoo please i really want to pl
is this is this worth it to just to try
to play this combo and there's not
really anything i could do about it
anyway
because they have to die first i don't
know if it's worth it just to try to do
that but uh you know how it is you know
how i am
uh i already have a new ruling in my
deck
might as well bring out the wolf uh he's
coming up anyway
let's go or aborts
okay
i'm just holding on to cards because i
want to see what happens
putting the balance back in order hey
hey [ __ ] hey
[Applause]
what you dick
what is wrong with you
you think you can just do that okay so
it would be a problem if i do run out of
cards because i think that is a thing
that could happen all right well my
marquee move is gone so i guess i gotta
do the black code to try to get things
out on the board
uh
damn i can't do the turkey vulture thing
i mean i could play the turkey vulture
and that would kill that that's actually
not a bad play i don't know if it's good
to keep it out there
uh
man i really want to do that thing but i
don't think i'm going to be able to so
why don't we just go for the big majamba
right away
let's get him out i don't know if he's
gonna be sacrificed right away or not
which would suck
but it is what it is
okay
and balance is restored
you capably endured the onslaught of
rare creatures but the true challenge
with forthcoming shadowy figures
appeared before you in their eyes
glimmered of recognition of kinship
colored by guilt
they were betraying you
oh reginald kaminsky i remember that one
fondly you dilweeds
you
dickholes uh might as well go get this
now because i'm gonna need it
hey why didn't you attack these things
whatever
just gonna
hold on to this for now
take that kaminsky you traitorous [ __ ]
stale fish hard choice
oh no don't take my actually don't don't
take my squirrel what are you gonna do
take my yeah get out of here
with that nonsense
all right well this is a win
uh does that mean he's not gonna do
anything on this next one i'm thinking
maybe no
take new fish easy all right you cannot
take this oroborus if you take the
auroboris i will be so mad he's going to
take the oroborz but i can't risk taking
the squirrels so
i might as well get
this out
oh wait no it's gonna be fine
okay so i'll lose a squirrel it's fine
it's fine losing a squirrel is fine or i
could get
this thing out i i don't know how this
board is gonna clear i'm i'm worried
about i'm gonna kill him this one but i
want to hold on to this wolf just in
case something goes horribly wrong
which it probably will
uh oh
uh oh buddy
this damned moon
it's dramatic yes
but it provides no
value to my board i wonder
oh no that's not what in the hell
now that
that is value
[Music]
you'll go yeah you're right you'll go
because you're gonna stink up this moon
you stink up the moon uh and uh that's
gonna be good for us all right you're
gonna kill the oroboris because that's
gonna make it stronger
and you're gonna stink up the moon
you're sure yeah you're sure because you
just stunk up the moon that's how it go
tidal lock at the beginning of its
owner's turn a card bearing the sigil
will pull small creatures like squirrels
into its orbit well i should get those
squirrels off the board then i'm gonna
do a move
i realize what what i should have been
doing for this is i should have been
sacrificing it a lot
because
that will make it stronger
sacrifice sacrifice
it is now stronger
i put that there
boom
suddenly i got a moon and i'll put that
there just because i think it's going to
pull one in there anyway
unless it pulls
oh
hi squirrel what is this weakening my
moon with its stinky sigil
that makes no sense
wounds do not have a sense of smell
this is not how i imagined this battle
going
yeah i didn't think you did yeah i
didn't think you did
then again you didn't think it through
very much did you buddy i don't think i
have enough to be able to get though
your ruling out there i'll do without it
for now i'll do without it for now and
i'll put the uh how many times have i
rung the bill ah man i know i should
have pulled a one cost card or a bone
card i'm dumb where's my long elk i
forgot about that
all right what if i just don't put a
squirrel in there
man this is easy man this is easy it was
really easy all right let's get the
rattler out i guess man this is
this is easy
i'm gonna goo you i'm serious you cannot
use that there's no possible use for it
i'll place it on the shelf over there
for now
my advice avoid it i mean i should wish
i'd tried that before
i can't really do anything it's fine
yeah yeah
well that was easy
you've really destroyed the moon
i suppose all that's left is to finish
me off
go on
okay
uh
well that didn't finish you off but i
thought it was gonna i mean i could get
an extra ruling out there but what's it
really gonna do at this point all right
go for it
bing
huh
oh my did i just
i think i just beat him
oh
what
[Applause]
[Music]
what
hey there card gamers i'm the lucky
carter and this is another pack opening
video today i am opening catch monsters
packs and digging for that epic shiny
transcender
okay ladies and gentlemen i am about to
open my first pack
feeling good about this one
what do we got here
okay
and our first rare is a
birch kin
not exactly a viable competitive card
but hey
it's a pretty one
next pack i gotta say these cards are
feeling extra silky today
i mean
they're so smooth not sure what they're
doing down there at the uh the card
factory but um these are feeling good in
my hands
okay
let's see what we got here jank cards
maybe a few additions to my draft cube
we'll see
and our rare for this pack is
bam dog not exactly riveting so far but
we have many packs to go
next pack here we come
you didn't even show him in a satisfying
way
hey there card gamers i'm the lucky
carter
yeah
there's a set of coordinates on this
card write that down write that down
looks like they were
drawn on with a pen write that down 49
degrees north 149 and 123 west
49 north 123 west i'd have to check but
i think that's pretty nearby
there we go
this uh card opening took a turn
how did you know to dig nothing about it
said to dig you didn't know that you
were coming for buried treasure what are
you talking about this seems awfully
suspicious
what is that it wasn't buried very deep
huh oh my god you guys i can't believe
it
there's actually something here
what well that's not gonna work anymore
i'm uh
i'm a little confused
[Music]
cheaper than a hmm steep ball really
all right fine
wow great video
okay
time to figure out what's on this thing
time to figure out what all this was
about anyway
floppy drives don't usually spin up like
that do they do they spin up like that i
can't remember god it's been so long
that did sound like a hard drive
spinning up but man it's been a long
time since i did floppy i i just
remember the chunk when you put them in
that looks familiar
all right well that was
yeah we're good here hey what's up pal
is that mine i do not celebrate often
and i saw them give gifts
but you challenger
you are worthy please do not be polite
dig in
you don't need to tell me twice i'm
digging in your surprise awaits i'm
going for it
very well come with me wait wet i wanted
to eat the thing stand right there i
wanted to eat the pile of squiggly meat
oh god are you naked please don't be
naked
am i
am i supposed to take a picture of you
there's no there's no film in there that
may be foolish there's no film in there
i will need that
i
you challenger or a champion
i i wish to commemorate your victory
oh please describe your name uh this is
uh
markimoo x
it looks like porn but it's supposed to
be like mega man x you know
stupid
you're a winner
i'm ready
i knew that wasn't the end there's more
in this cabin to discover there's more
in this cavend lock and part of it is
coming from that group
and i wish i'd played my vulture
squirrel combo the last challenger
managed to defeat me a rare event
go and ask how they did it
you will find him hanging from the door
over there
you're starting deck just sto you don't
look so good what is happening to you
all right anyway uh goodbye i gotta do a
thing
i almost oh i can do that i can do that
no problem oh hey look at that oh that's
nice oh man scruffy that guy was gruffy
looking real scruffy looking can i play
marky max
probably not he what's up
the pain is unbearable
even after all these years
what do you want
i have very little to live for these
days
ah i watched that dagger do its work
for a moment i felt in my misery and
company
oh but it had its own noble purpose
surely a step towards freeing the master
watching the angler lose
now that soothes my pain
an old rival of mine that fisherman
i didn't know he had this much dialogue
i would have picked an easier voice he
busted me this time but i will have
another chance i witnessed the final
defeat of leshi over there
quite a spectacle
though i had no hope that it would bring
me freedom
for that to happen
i think you would need something special
up your sleeve
all right that's enough of that
oh
bonelord
i summon thee
but anyway i'm out of time for this
episode oh mushys
nice i'm out of time for this episode
we will continue the mystery of how to
get out of this predicament in the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always i'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you